Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the king of random today
We're going to be trying out something a little bit different in that this whole video is going to be  one
Take. We're going to show you an experiment from start to finish, without cutting the camera to several different angles
We wanted to try this because, it gives you a better sense of what it's like to really do an experiment in real time
Unfortunately, that does mean that when I garbled my words our trip over something
We're gonna leave that video footage in hopefully there won't be too much of that
Not too long ago, we had a video where we showed you taking lithium batteries and lighting them on fire
They kind of exploded and then  burned with a really bright magenta flame
And it looked really cool a few people commented pointing out that we should try taking that same lithium and dropping it into some water
That's what we're gonna try today because lithium should react with water and
Hopefully we'll get that same bright pink flame
Now as a first test. I have a strip of lithium that I've already taken out of a battery
And I'm just gonna try lighting it on fire with a blowtorch
Check out our setup, we've got here, we're gonna take one battery will show you taking the lithium out of that one
We've got these three batteries. Which are already partially open, but not completely and
We'll be removing the lithium from those
Have here some lithium that I've already taken out of one of the batteries and now we're gonna try lighting that on fire with a
Blowtorch and see if we can get that pink flame. We're looking for
Let's come over to a slightly drier spot
I don't want to put it down on the water because as this experiment may indicate it should react with water
Here's a dry spot
Get the blowtorch working
Glasses on
Wow!
There we have it a fairly exciting and almost violent reaction.
That may have even put a little divot in the concrete pad. That's pretty exciting
So now let's look at how we get that lithium.
I have here a an ultimate lithium battery, and you have to have the ultimate lithium kind
Or it's something else entirely different inside, so let's take a look at opening one of these up
It's just a piece of plastic sheeting around the outside
I'm using our wire cutters to undo the crimped metal holding the top of this battery on
There we go this little top piece pops right off
Now we kind of need to peel this
Kind of like we're opening a weird-shaped tiny little metal pan
Now we can see what's inside of our lithium battery here, it's a roll of
Some plastic a couple kinds of metal and some chemicals
But different parts of metal or attach to the positive and negative ends of the battery
Let's see if we can pull this whole roll out
Not really sure what the best way to do this is
Open up the casing a little more still
This is the part we usually just edit right out of the videos
Because it's not very exciting to watch
But as I said the point is to really see what it's like to do an experiment in real time
Sometimes it's not super smooth there we go
So now we have a
Tab that's part of what connects the metal strips inside to the housing
We can set down my tools here
Now we can start to unroll this and just trying to make sure my hands are dry so I don't start
Setting anything off as I unroll it
We've got two strips in here
This one back here is our lithium and
I'm not 100% sure what this one is honestly, but it smells kind of like rotten eggs
So it might have sulfur on it or something
All right now the whole video is going to be one take until after I've said my finished closing bit
And then we're going to show you some other
Slow-mo behind-the-scenes footage kind of so our cameraman is going to get those cameras started now
And then I'm going to drop this lithium strip into our bowl of water
Alright here goes
Lithium in a bowl of water
Boom pink flame and orange flame and lots of smoke
Beautiful that reacted so quickly - ooh, and then it popped
Wow I think that actually started melting the glass on my bowl holy cow
Check this out like there is a rough patch here, and I it it could just be something built up on the surface
But I'm pretty sure
That started etching down into the glass
That's crazy. Well. I've got some other batteries already torn open. Oh that broke the glass
Well that's exciting
That's not even the part where oh there. We go it started over here. Where it had heated it up and
Then it just cracked all the way along here and opened that up down there
Well, that's the kind of thing that would usually be thrown into random happens at the end of the video
Well the bowls already broken
But I've still got a couple of batteries
Probably don't want to let those get wet
Actually, let's uh try tossing one of those in
See what happens this could be stupid to me
Well it's in the bowl
it's gonna try and unwrap one more and throw it into what's left of my bowl most of my bowl is gone, but
It's still holding some water
There it is
There's the edge gloves are all wet so I'm a little nervous about touching this
All right, there's our lithium bundling it up. You don't wanna start those cameras again, or should I just throw it in
All right, I'm just gonna throw it in here we go
And it ignites again whoo
There's a bright little burning ball of metal in the water
Very cool well our battery that I just threw in there seems to be corroding a little bit
But it doesn't look like it's actually going to go very far. It is wrapped up in other pieces of metal and
in some paper and whatever the other chemicals are in there, but
There's a chunk of our reactive lithium, you know are still very much broken and ruined bolt these things happen
Bowls aren't too expensive for you, but there you go lithium torn out of a lithium battery
Stripped of its other wrappings and whatever else is around it crumpled up a little bit and then drop into water
It ignites beautifully it has that super bright pink and orange glow to it. It's really cool
it's a very fun color and
Overall this is a pretty fun and easy experiment and you can see exactly how long it took you know
It's not that easy to open the batteries
That was the biggest delay is watching you slowly peel back the metal shell of the battery not exciting
I know
But hopefully we made up for it by showing you how it's saying
how exciting it is to drop our lithium right into water that really burst into flames very entertaining Lee and
Obviously gets really hot hot enough that it melted the side of the bowl
which thing cracked and is now worthless next it's run away, but
it's a cool experiment, and I'm glad that some people commented in the other video that we should try this out and
It way it was fun. It's really fun to do
I'm not saying that you should do this at home
But if you do do at home you know try to be very careful very well ventilated area a little too much ventilation today
Honestly wearing gloves is wearing long sleeves as wearing glasses. Just be extremely careful. If you do anything like this
Thank you for joining us for this video today
Remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at the king of random column. See you there
Less crumpled-up, let's see if it still lights on fire
Hmm not so much this random happens, it's a different cut I know